Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Heath Drazen, who's creator and host
of the podcast Extremely American, produced
in partnership with post-Industrial Media
and Boise State Public Radio.
You can find extremely American everywhere
you get podcasts.
Heath, it's really great having you on today.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Great to be here, thanks.
Speaker 1: So, you know, it certainly since
the Trump riots and even before that, we've
been covering militia groups, so-called militia
groups for for a long period of time.
You covered the Pennsylvania volunteer militia,
which is sort of adjacent to some of the other
groups, maybe people in my audience are familiar
with.
Can you talk a little bit about how did you
get interested in this?
How did you start covering them?
What are some of their views?
How would we characterize these groups?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I mean, I've been covering
the militia movement and kind of the broader,
far right movement for a number of years now.
What kind of got me started on this podcast
is I started seeing them get a lot more politically
active kind of come out of the words come
out of the mountains and be much more visible
in everyday life.
The Pennsylvania volunteers, they are an interesting
group because they're led by a guy named Christian
Yingling.
And he played a pretty.
He played a pretty notable role in Charlottesville
in 2017.
And your listeners probably recognize that
that was the the white supremacist rally in
Charlottesville that also drew in a lot of
militia groups who said they were there to
basically keep the peace between right wing
protesters and left wing counterprotesters.
Some people question that.
So Yingling was there.
He actually got sued and agreed to never come
back to Charlottesville with the militia.
So he's he's been in the news.
He's a very sort of colorful character.
So I got to know him through that.
And I had been doing a number of interviews
with him and trying to get in on his training
because I wanted to give listeners of my podcast,
Extremely American.
I wanted to give them a real feel for what
it's like to be at a training with a militia,
what they do get there on the gun range with
them.
So that's what brought me out there.
It took me a while to get their trust, but
they eventually let me come to their monthly
training, which is deep in the Pennsylvania
woods, kind of out in these rolling mountains
in western Pennsylvania, this sort of classic
site, you would imagine a militia training
happening at.
Yeah, that's what that's what got me there.
Speaker 1: And you know, we've spoken to people
who who have I don't want to use the term
infiltrated but who have been sort of like
granted access to different types of extremists
and different different journalists and reporters
take different approaches in terms of whether
they just remain extraordinarily neutral in
terms of their opinion of what it is that
they're observing or whether they are sort
of engaged in conversations about their views
as to what these groups do.
What's the dynamic like when you're with these
folks in terms of how they see you and sort
of what the conversations are like?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I mean, so if you if you
if you listen to the podcast and especially
episode one with this group, what you'll hear
is I let them tell their own story.
But you know, I don't I don't just sit on
the sidelines.
If somebody says something outlandish, I challenge
them.
Yeah.
So I'll give you an example.
You know, Christian Yingling at one point
he's talking about being between you went
to a Trump rally where they were counterprotesters
and he was standing with his guys between
the left and right wing protesters.
Well, he talks about the story about how he
was basically trying to get the left wing
protesters to back up.
Now they're in a public park, right?
He has no authority there.
He's a private citizen and he's telling them
to back up and, you know, and he's telling
them, basically, if you don't back up, I'm
going to break your leg.
So the guys?
And that's, you know, that's where I do step
in and I'm like, Well, now hold on.
Under whose authority do you do that?
And so there's back and forth like that.
I do want to let them tell their own story
because I think that's more interesting for
a listener than me just spouting off.
But certainly, I'm not going to let something
like that just sort of twist in the wind.
So there's some kind of fun back and forth
about that about January six, about Donald
Trump.
So, yeah, you know, I'll challenge people
when I feel like that is appropriate.
But I do also want people to hear their viewpoint
because I think understanding these groups
is much more important than than slamming
them, for example, just to just to sort of
feel good
Speaker 1: at the individual level.
You I've spoken to a lot of former hate group
members, including KKK and some other groups,
and the one theme that is present in all of
their stories was they were sucked in because
of a sort of personal vulnerability of their
situation that came often from sort of like
the prototypical absent or broken family or
lack of direction from parents.
It's like a very similar story that they all
tell.
Is that a common back story in the folks that
you see in the militia groups or is that different?
Speaker 4: So I would say there's a little
bit, a little bit of yes and no there, I've
certainly met people who fit that mold.
I think with militia groups, though, because
most of them, they're they're not explicitly
racist and a lot of them actually will at
least outwardly reject that.
I think they have a bit of broader appeal,
I think.
I think when you're talking about like explicitly
white supremacist groups, I think that recruitment
is a little tougher and you really have to
to to try harder with the militia groups.
They try to tell, they try to have a bigger
tent.
I guess you can say so.
What I do find, though, is people who are
very disaffected with what's happening in
America.
They might be uncomfortable with a changing
country.
They might be uncomfortable with increasing
diversity.
They may not say it like that, but they will
talk about certain things like transgender
rights come up a lot, and that makes a lot
of people in this movement uncomfortable.
They'll talk about critical race theory now,
whether or not that's actually a real thing
in American schools.
You know, that's obviously something that
people are debating.
But there is a discomfort with the changing
America that draws people in.
And I think certainly Donald Trump's rise
to power and some of the things he said, they
do feel more empowered than they have and
I think made him feel more comfortable coming
out in the open as opposed to just training
out in the woods.
Speaker 1: Is there?
Is there a notable undertone of anti-Semitism
in these groups?
Speaker 4: I would actually say no.
I am a Jewish reporter.
I, you know, I did not feel that directly.
I did speak to one very prominent Jewish member
of the three percent militia in Washington
state.
He figures prominently in episode three, and
we talk a little bit about his background
now.
Is that to say that there is not a strain
of anti-Semitism?
No.
I also ran into some really offensive stuff
where people would talk about it.
They would compare COVID protocols to Nazi
ism now.
Is that directly anti-Semitism?
We can debate that, but it's really very offensive,
I think, to a lot of people.
So I would say explicitly, No, you do get
that undercurrent with some people, and I
think you do get some sort of explaining away
of stuff.
Speaker 1: How prominent is the presence of
law enforcement, current or former and military
current and former in your experience in these
groups?
Speaker 4: I run into a lot of ex-military
in these groups as you run into a lot of people
who kind of are in the, you know, I wish I
would have served kind of mold.
But you do run into a lot of veterans.
You run into some law enforcement.
It gets kind of murky there.
There's certainly some law enforcement that
have been supportive.
There's a whole sheriffs movement called the
Constitutional Sheriffs Movement, and they
have elected sheriffs all over the country.
Joe Arpaio in Arizona was part of that, and
they're very friendly to militias.
Now you also get law enforcement who are dead
set against them because they see their anti-government
rhetoric as also anti law enforcement.
So it's a very mixed bag.
But I would say the veteran part of it that
is a robust part of the military are the militia
movement.
Speaker 1: Do the militia groups get along
with each other or do they see each other
as competitors or they believe they aren't?
You know, do they have problems with the ideologies
of some of the other groups?
Speaker 4: So that's a great question.
This might not be surprising, but anti-government
movements are not very good at centralized
control.
So there is a lot of bickering back and forth
and a lot of infighting and frankly, just
some some honest disagreements where you have
groups that absolutely will disavow another
group, including different three percent groups.
There's a group in Georgia that has a Confederate
flag in their logo, and some of the more some
of the some of the other three percenters
in the West, you know, they'll look to them
and say, We absolutely want nothing to do
with those guys.
They're racist and we reject them.
So it's a mixed bag.
They do come together over two things a radical
view of limited government and pretty much
absolutist gun rights and a restriction on
gun rights they see as a red line.
I would say almost every militia group agrees
on those two things.
Speaker 1: What is the ah, let's see how I
can phrase this what?
There's the fear among observers of some of
these groups that at some point they're going
to do like their big thing, you know, like
the.
You think about Jim Jones in Jonestown.
And eventually there was like the mass suicide
of the nine hundred and fifty people in South
America.
And it was sort of like the culmination of
the entire thing.
And there's the fear that some equivalent
not not killing themselves, necessarily, but
there's the equivalent that they're building
to some kind of big event.
Do you get the sense that that's the eventual
goal?
Or are they there more of as like as a constant
low grade protection as they see it against
the tyranny and oppression of the government
or whatever the case may be without planning,
like some big event?
Speaker 4: I think what you're seeing is and
what I get into an extremely American is this
shift away from that kind of thinking more
to, hey, we have this moment where we've got
more mainstream support.
Let's try to change government from the inside.
There's a lot of younger leaders who I would
say are much more politically savvy than the
old guard from the Michigan militia and those
kind of groups.
And you know, they're they're targeting the
local school boards, their library boards.
They're picking off state Senate and state
legislature seats.
So that's not to say we couldn't have that.
I mean, we've seen it.
We've seen it at least twice.
We saw Cliven Bundy's ranch, where all these
militia guys were pointing weapons at federal
agents that carry guns quickly.
And we saw it in Oregon, where Ammon Bundy,
Cliven son, had an armed standoff of his own.
Now we could totally see that again.
I think a lot of these guys are much more
focused on trying to bring government to the
right as opposed to having an armed confrontation,
even though when you ask them, they will admit
they are simultaneously training to fight
against the government and kind of trying
to be a part of it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Well, so that was going to be my next thing,
which is you talked about the presence of
military veterans.
There's in hypothetical discussions about
what might happen if one of these groups really
tried something big.
There's the reality that eventually they might
be confronting not just police, but if they
really wreaked enough havoc.
The National Guard, or they would sort of
be against the military, but they are made
up.
They have a significant former military presence.
How do they conceive of that, of the idea
that ultimately the force that might stop
them is the one that many of them were once
a part of?
Speaker 4: Right, and that's something you
can't escape.
When I talked to militia members and leaders
about that, often they kind of deflects at
first.
But when I pressed them, they admit yes.
I mean that you can't talk about fighting
the government without the possibility.
And really, the almost probability if you
fight the government that your guns are going
to be pointed at law enforcement and or troops.
Now what they'll say if you press them is,
you know, righteous righteous troops and law
enforcement will step aside because the battle
will be righteous for the militia guys.
But it's absolutely something that hangs in
the background.
And you can't avoid it.
And when you look at those standoffs, they
were against law enforcement and they weren't
against troops that they were against law
enforcement.
And in the case of the Oregon standoff, you
know, there was a deadly, deadly shootout
and a man got killed.
So it's not it's not theoretical that could
happen.
And it has happened
Speaker 1: in terms of the political alignment
when it comes to Democrats, Republicans, etc.
I mean, you made it clear they want to move
the government to the right.
Their most important issues certainly align
more with the Republican Party than the Democratic
Party.
But like, is there any political diversity
within these groups?
Speaker 4: Yeah, and they also get into that
in the podcast because I think the political
angle on these groups, it makes them so much
more interesting now.
I mean, I should say yes and no.
Are any of them Democrats that I've met?
No.
Do they have diverse political views?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there there is a diversity of views.
Some are more libertarian, sort of live and
let live.
Some of them are really much more sort of
fundamentalist, far right groups.
And I would say more of them are of that ilk.
And that's why they're targeting school boards.
They talk a lot about critical race theory
and culture war issues.
And I think that's a big change from the 1990s.
In the 1990s, they might have been very conservative,
but they were very much pox on both parties.
They're all the same.
These guys today, they're much more involved
in Republican politics, and I think that's
a really important shift because they've sort
of pick sides in a way that they didn't in
the past.
They just saw all government is bad before.
Speaker 1: Right, that that's interesting.
And there's also the question as to how responsible
Donald Trump is for that and whether the political
activism may fade to some degree if Trumpism
fades.
I mean, that's a question we've had about
the general voter who never voted before Trump
was pulled in to vote for Trump, and the now
it's unclear how engaged they stay, right?
Speaker 4: Yeah, and I think I think that's
the the one of the biggest questions hanging
over this movement now, I think they were
on the rise before Trump.
I saw them rising before Trump, but they were
they were supercharged by Trump.
They saw somebody at the highest echelon of
power, really.
They saw him as supportive.
Now they talk a lot about basically taking
that momentum and continuing that kind of
Trumpism without Trump.
I think we're going to see I think I think
that's that's a real open question.
I think these midterm elections might have
a lot to do with it, but they're trying to
keep that momentum up right now.
And I do think we'll see if Trump jumps back
in 2024, but without him, they do potentially
lose momentum.
But I guess we'll just have to see how far
right the right wing of American politics
has gone.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt.
Yeah.
No, that's it's without a doubt an open question
that we're all sort of anxiously waiting,
waiting to start getting some answers to.
The podcast is extremely American creator
and host of the podcast Heath Dru's, and has
been talking to us about his investigative
work.
Heath, really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Thanks so much, I appreciate you
having me on.